Jean d'Ormesson bonsoir très heureux de
vous avoir avec nous vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous confirmer que apparemment
vous seriez le seul immortel vraiment
immortel contrairement aux autres
vous connaissez la définition du Cocteau
nous sommes immortels pour la durée de
notre vie après nous nous changeons en
fauteuil
d'ailleurs vous avez été élu le mec le
mieux conservé pour son âge par
l'électricité
on disait William qu'est-ce que vous
voudriez qu'au 10 de vous dans 100 ans
et répondait je voudrais qu'on dise il
n'est pas mal pour son âge
quel client ce jour-là me sont vous êtes
le meilleur client de la télévision ce
jour alors on fait comment à votre âge
pour avoir l’œil qui brille comme ça
est-ce que c'est la passion de la vie ou
de la conjonctivite surtout pas de sport
bon jean vous connaissez l'émission donc
en P1 nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de votre vie de votre
œuvre et de ces fameuses lentilles
bleues qui font tout votre charme
pourquoi vous l'avez jamais dit que
Xavier des lentilles en fait
alors en P2 nous recevrons de nouveaux
invités pour commenter avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine Clémentine
autant vous la connaissez Clémentine qui
nous annoncera qu'elle arrête la
politique et qu'elle veut relancer les
coco girl avec Martine Aubry et
Marie-George Buffet voilà on s'est un
scoop ce soir dans ces vétéria elle
raconte tout ça dans un livre intitulé
transformé à gauche qui est publié aux
éditions du Seuil voilà notre troisième
invité sera Thomas N'Gijol le noir le
plus drôle de la télé depuis Michel Leeb
Thomas qui sera la cigale les 12-13 et
14 novembre dans son one man qui
s'intitule à bloc voilà en P3 après le
zapping et Guillon nous accueillerons
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
Raphaël Ricci Raffi de la Star Ac pour
son livre témoignage je ne chanterai pas
ce soir tant mieux moi non plus je ne
chanterai pas ce soir
alors c'est grâce à elle qu'on a
découvert des gens comme Jennifer
Nolwenn et le diffrégier Magali Quentin
enfin la promis de s'excuser ce soir
[Applaudissements]
alors cette année il y a une nouveauté
dans l'émission je donne mon numéro de
portable donc si vous avez des
commentaires des critiques des idées
appelez le numéro qui s'affiche voilà on
va commencer par le premier message
vocal oui bonjour Magalie animatrice
dans une maison de retraite en Corse je
voulais dire que l'émission du 17
octobre avec William Régis a fait du
bien d'entendre ses paroles parce que ça
c'est un moment que j'ai envie de dire
ça tout fort et tout et maman de trois
enfants j'ai pas le temps mais c'était
dans l'idée de de faire un petit bouquin
un peu dénoncé toutes ces pratiques
voilà et comme il dit ça se passait en
crèche ça sera autre chose voilà ça fait
du bien de le dire merci ciao merci à
vous merci à vous madame alors beaucoup
beaucoup de messages sur le témoignage
de William régot sur les maisons de
retraite je crois que tout le monde
était extrêmement bouleversé c'est des
choses dont on parle jamais donc
beaucoup de gens qui nous disent bravo
vous avez eu raison et tout et d'autres
qui sont pas d'accord on écoute oui bien
moi je trouve
que des maisons de retraite alors que ma
maman vient justement de qui d'entité
une en fin de vie et elle a été
extrêmement bien accompagnée et la
famille aussi c'est une maison de
retraite qui est à Rueil et je leur dis
chapeau bas voilà donc les avis sont
partagés vous vous êtes dans une maison
de retraite excellente l'Académie
française non mais c'est vrai c'est
sympa il y a les gratte les mois gâteaux
les plus gâteaux tout ça on s'entend
très bien vous connaissez l'histoire des
deux qui se rencontrent non les deux
académiciens seront comptés lundi
comment va notre confrère un tel et
l'autre dit à moitié gâteaux et le
premier dit ah il va mieux
voilà l'émission s'appelle Salut les
terriens et le groupe les grément de
fortune
alors Jean rebonsoir on va parler de
vous c'est ce qui vous intéresse le plus
de toute façon
alors vous publiez deux livres saveur du
temps et l'enfant qui attendait un train
tous les deux aux éditions Éloïse
d'Ormesson alors saveur du temps ce sont
des chroniques du temps qui passe des
textes que vous avez écrit pour la
presse de 1948 à 2009 et là son père de
60 ans Alors à la relecture est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment de vous répéter
ou de vous contredire je me contredis
très peu je crois que ce que j'ai écrit
il y a 60 ans je l'écrirai encore
aujourd'hui c'est bien et y compris les
erreurs les bêtises les j'ai changé
assez peu le monde a peut-être pu
changer autour de moi que je n'ai changé
moi vous êtes plus solide que le monde
finalement alors vous êtes souvent
trompé ou non oui oui bien sûr sur Mao
parce que quand il est mort vous avez
chanté sa grandeur
souligner sa grandeur qui est vrai mais
on pouvait aussi souligner d'autres
choses à propos de Mao quand communie
est mort j'étais persuadé que le régime
des Molas a laissé crouler comme je me
suis trompé alors il y a quand même des
points communs dans tous ces textes si
cette idée de guetter perdue un peu
comme quand on parlait de l'Ancien
Régime au 19e siècle les gens qui
avaient connu l'Ancien Régime disait il
y avait quelque chose qui a disparu avec
la révolution je crois qu'on peut le
dire mais je crois aussi qu'on l'a
toujours dit oui à toutes les époques à
toutes les époques qu'on s'est dit ah
comme c'était mieux autant de nos
grands-parents je crois que toutes les
époques c'était mais on a retrouvé un
texte à Babylone qui date de 3000 ans
avant Jésus-Christ il y avait déjà un
mec qui disait tout fout le camp
extraordinaire et plateau disait les
jeunes gens d'aujourd'hui sont vraiment
insupportables absolument donc
finalement ça a toujours été et vous
savez aujourd'hui on dit beaucoup
l'ordinateur internet détruisent la
culture et Platon disait l'écriture
c'est une catastrophe pour la culture
parce que à partir de l'écriture vous me
savez plus les textes par coeur avant
Platon on savait par cœur il y a des
lycée et puis quand l'écriture c'est
imposée
de pas travailler avec les ordinateurs
c'est exactement pareil alors il y a
quand même une date clé dans vos écrits
c'est le 10 mai 1940 que l'effondrement
de la France pour vous c'est rien avant
et un après c'est à dire faut dire à nos
plus jeunes amis téléspectateurs que
c'est le moment où la France a perdu
contre l'Allemagne nazie on se joue à la
France et les coulée et évidemment les
gens qui ont connu ça comme moi c'est à
partir de là les catastrophes après le
ressembler beaucoup moins grand tous
s'écroulait vous savez tous s'écouler et
il n'y avait plus d'espérance parce que
l'Amérique et la Russie n'étaient pas en
guerre la Russie
à Paris à l'époque et on se disait il
n'y a plus d'espérance la seule
espérance était portée par le général de
Gaulle voilà qui disait nous avons perdu
une bataille mais nous n'avons pas perdu
la guerre alors justement cette perte de
gaieté de dont vous parlez elle est dû
aussi au fait qu'il y a plus d'espérance
c'est-à-dire qu'à l'époque il y avait
encore le catholicisme pour certains et
le communisme pour nous aujourd'hui il y
a plus d'idéologie qui puisse donner aux
gens de l'espoir quoi et il faut les
faire réinventer un monde nouveau je
trouve d'ailleurs ça très excitant et je
pense qu'il y a pas de raison de se
laisser aller ou désespoir l'autre livre
que vous publiez c'est l'enfant qui
attendait un train ça compte pour
enfants c'est deux livres sont publiés
par votre fille Héloïse et par son mari
Gilles Cohen Solal vous avez vécu
comment son incursion dans les médias à
travers strip-tease
j'aime beaucoup ma fille ouais elle aime
ce garçon
donc je suis indulgent pour ce garçon je
crois d'ailleurs qu'après ce mini
scandale quand même où il avait fait des
déclarations un peu intempestives sur
les auteurs de la maison sur l'édition
en général votre épouse lui a quand même
passé un savon un
il a été sauvé par le roman Giscard par
Frédéric Mitterrand
Sarkozy tout ça ça a fait oublier le
alors ce qui est incroyable avec vous
donc vous avez 84 ans vous êtes toujours
dans le coup récemment je lisais dans
dans le magazine Lire et dans l'Express
jandot la nouvelle
idole des jeunes
alors il disait loin de se ringardiser
le standalien est devenu une icône la
première pop star en costume flanelle
extraordinaire quelle chance alors on va
vous poser des questions que tout le
monde se pose
qui ne vous aime pas il y a des gens qui
qui m'aiment pas et même qui me
détestent ce qui a c'est que je ne
déteste personne j'ai remarqué que ce
qui fatiguait et ce qui vieillissait
c'est de détester les gens voilà
bien sûr vous avez 84 ans et vous avez
déclaré récemment je suis vieux j'ai
commencé à comprendre que j'étais vieux
à partir du moment où les gens m'ont dit
comme vous êtes jeune vous avez bonne
nuit
c'était très rare quand j'étais jeune
qu'on me dise comme vous avez bonne mine
quand vous avez bonne mine quand vous
êtes jeune ça ça met la puce à l'oreille
est-ce que pour finir vous pourriez nous
faire votre fameux formidable
je veux bien faire formidable mais je
fais plutôt épatant
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu